STACEY: ARE YOU DOING A ZOOM
CALL?
ADAM: YEP.
MATT MAGGIE TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID.
WE WILL TALK TO HIM VIA ZOOM.
STACEY: WE HOPE HE IS WELL.
ADAM: HE'S POTENTIALLY ABLE TO
COME BACK SUNDAY.
GOOD JOB BY ROBINSON.
STACEY: HEADS UP PLAY.
ADAM: GREEN ONCE THE CARUSO
PICK.
HE WANTED A FOUL ON WALKER.
WHAT A PASS BY CARUSO TO LAVINE!
STACEY: WHAT A PASS!
ADAM: CARUSO JUST KNOCKED LAVINE
DOWN IN CELEBRATION.
[LAUGHTER]
LAVINE HAD TO GET UP.
STACEY: I DON'T THINK HE SAW.
ADAM: THAT IS THE FIRST TIME IT
HAS WORKED, BUT ROBINSON
COULDN'T FINISH THE DUNK.
THERE IS A FOUL AGAINST LONZO
BALL, HIS FIRST.
STACEY: WHAT A PASS.
ADAM: SLICKNESS RIGHT HERE.
STACEY: LOOKING LIKE A WILDCAT
QUARTERBACK.
NICE PLAY.